bitcoin's been one of the most
interesting assets over the last two
years it's captured the imagination the
hearts and minds of many many investors
around the world one of the big
milestones over the past two years was
when a public company microstrategy
decided to put bitcoin on their balance
sheet and they didn't just put a couple
they took 85 percent of their balance
sheet at the time and they went ahead
and they bought bitcoin on top of that
they've continued to buy more and more
and more now that was great when
bitcoin's price was going from about 10
000 all the way up to the all-time high
of 69 000
price went up and they kept buying more
but since the price has crashed there's
been all sorts of fear uncertainty and
doubt in the market would microstrategy
turn around and actually sell their
bitcoin would they give up on that
bitcoin treasury strategy and if they
had any sort of liquidation price would
it be triggered would there be some sort
of cascading effect now of course
eventually we were going to get the
answer and this morning michael saylor
the ceo of microstrategy he announced
that microstrategy has bought about 480
more bitcoin for about 10 million
dollars an average price of 20 817 per
bitcoin they now hold almost 130 000
bitcoin which they've spent just under 4
billion dollars to acquire
their average price sits just above 30
000
now why is this significant well we have
the public company that has been the
face of a bitcoin treasury strategy
they're continuing to dollar cost
average into bitcoin regardless of
whether the price is up or down
as they continue to execute this
strategy it ends up giving confidence to
the market that microstrategy's bitcoin
strategy is not going away they are
long-term investors they are long-term
thinkers and they believe that this is
the best strategy for their business
nobody knows what the future holds but
what we do know is that this strategy is
something that this company and this
executive team and this board of
directors is very committed to they've
said over and over and over again they
don't care what the price does they
simply want to continue to convert their
profits and their balance sheet into
bitcoin and they believe that will serve
them best over the coming years
this trade that they are pursuing will
either go down as the best trade on wall
street over the last decade or there
will be a lot of people a lot of the
critics that'll run around and say i
told you so time will tell what happens
here but you have to tip your cap to
michael saylor and microstrategy even
though the price is down about 70 from
its all-time high they're continuing to
acquire bitcoin they liked it at 69 000
they love it at 20 000 it appears be
fascinating to see how many bitcoin can
they scoop up at these lower prices at
the end of all this michael saylor will
end up owning a lot of bitcoin the
question is just how much will that
bitcoin be worth in us dollar terms hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time